pressure that moves over our area will  certainly be feeling that warm to hot  weather  here's a look outside right now a  beautiful shot there  portions of the strip certainly a  gorgeous evening  our temperatures around the valley are  also holding up quite nice right now so  we have 66  mostly mid 60s what we're seeing around  the valley 66 along the strip we're  seeing those mid 60s to low 60s  over on the west side of town centennial  hills you're only at 62  49 at kyle canyon you're seeing 64  degrees in henderson just 61 right  around sunrise mountain regionally  some of your temps boulder city 68  searchlight 64. you're seeing 77  down in laughlin and mesquite is 66  degrees at this  hour tomorrow morning waking up you're  going to be around in those low 60s so 6